he went on to create one of the most
iconic characters in TV history and
jean-luc Picard but you've been able to
do so many other things since how are
you were able to avoid being boxed in by
the character like other people from
Star Trek franchises ever have struggled
it has not been without struggle and
it's something that I'm learning to let
go of a little bit now but it still
controls some of my decision-making and
choices that I make quite soon after the
seven seasons of the series wraps and
maybe we made one or two movies I was I
was living here I lived here for 17
years I thought my life in the UK was
over everything was happening here and
there was a particular project I was
really keen to be part of I had a role
in it that I wanted to play a nice
supporting role and getting in to meet
the director was proving really
difficult and finally I made it my agent
with whom I had developed a wonderful
relationship got me into his office and
we had a nice meeting everything went
really well and the director said to me
look you're a terrific actor I really
like your work but I've got to say to
you why would I want John Luke Picard in
my movie that was hard to hear something
that I had done had never been held
against me before yes and it made me
highly sensitive to the fact that there
was a potential downside to having had
so much success in a successful series
in a certain role who had a very
distinctive way of being and very soon
after that we we done the first movie I
remember now and I remember saying to my
agent I don't care what my next job is
but it has got to have nothing to do
with
fiction nothing to do with space nothing
to do with having a rank nothing to do
with sitting in a chair god bless him he
came up with the role of sterling in the
movie Jeffrey which was as a role a gay
man whose path was dying of AIDS and who
they had both decided that comedy was
the way to deal with this tragedy that
was happening to them and and so the
movie was quite successful but the role
was a transformation and I think you
know all the time that has gone by since
then I am I
there is a little voice inside my head
that says how far removed is this role
from the cut I mean can I convince that
director this time that he won't get
John Luke Picard you'll get somebody
else like you know like Charles Xavier
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]